welcome everybody um thanks for having
me my name is Richie Vin I'm the author
of polers and since a few months also
the founder of a company with your very
original name polers
Incorporated
um yeah I have a background in machine
learning and software development and um
yeah as I said I'm the AL of polers and
started a company and today I'm going to
talk a bit about polers um first a short
introduction what polars is then um
we're going to talk about Expressions
which are one of the most important
things in polers and then we're going to
talk about optimizations and
parallelisms um both are very
fundamental in polers and we guarantee a
lot about it um and I want to show you
we're going to end off with a new thing
sort of a demo on polar's plugins which
is something really new um and we're
really happy about so we want to share
this um can I get a quick raise of hands
of people who already know about
pols nice and using it is that the same
check okay and the rest who knows
pondos no that should be higher right
that's not not correct okay so that
shows we cannot trust these these
completely um so okay what polers is
polers is sort of a synergy synergy
between
um um all data frame libraries uh for a
single machine talk about data table
deeper pandas and um databases postgress
snowflake um and actually what we saw in
the world that for a single machine we
saw that uh
data frames were actually reasonably
naive and data frames did all the smarts
databases did all the smart stuff they
come with optimizers they can handle
data sets that that are way larger than
than your uh RAM capacity and they also
seem to be super fast so um yeah it did
it didn't make sense that we didn't have
all these nice things in a data frame
library and what we wanted what I wanted
with polers is that we Empower your
laptop we Empower your single machine we
want to go use all these all these
resources we have available um we have
discs so we must so we can use it we can
probably process data we don't have to
fit everything in memory we have
multiple cores my machine has got 16
cores let's use it as much as we can so
that is the goal um a polus is sort of
an Synergy between these two worlds it's
data frame Library which respects all
the research done in um relational
database management um um a few things
which we have and which are important
here are um one thing is very important
and that's we that that's that we have
lazy evaluation if you don't have lazy
evaluation you cannot do anything
because you just have to do what the
user says and you uh an example is sort
this data and then give me the head then
I first have to sort all the data
because that's what you
requested but you only wanted the first
10 rows and actually a top K algorithm
would have been way cheaper but we have
to have a lazy API to be able to even
recognize this polus comes in two apis
we have an eager API and a lazy API and
they are both similar or very similar so
the eager API is just to to uh for ease
of use and if you want to go to more of
a uh an ETL pipeline you transform this
into a lazy just by saying okay now it's
lazy and now we collect it the end and
then polers will do all the
optimizations for you um we minimize
materializations we do this in very we
do this very often in a lot of
operations for instance as I said if you
do do a join or a group buy and you only
want the first 10 rows you shouldn't
finish this whole whole operation first
so in that sense we only materialize
what's needed and this already saves a
lot of a lot of compute um we have data
types which are constructed to amortise
access and allocation costs uh as a
counter example the default Punda string
is the opposite of this they're
improving they're going to P Arrow um
but we also we also are Arrow native but
we are very aware on how we construct
these these data types for instance if
we return something in parallel we can
actually we know how to uh create a list
and we know how how we can do this stuff
in parallel so we um yeah we are very
careful in how to create how to
materialize our our uh yeah our
results um it's written in a very in a
lowlevel language um and this is very
important to have full control over
performance and over memory especially
memory you need to be able to reason
about memory to be able to get good
performance otherwise you will have cach
misses everywhere um cach is one of the
most important things if you're talking
about local compute so it's written in
Rust and this gives us one full memory
control and two it gives us uh a lot of
um what the second thing is safety but
the third thing thing is also it gives
us a lot of good trading a lot of good
concurrency Primitives and uh we can
actually be very sure that we don't
deadlock or we don't make these very
hard mistakes um and it's designed for
Effective parallelism and effective
parallelism is something that isn't very
common in Python uh if we talk about job
lip or or multiprocessing that's not
effective parallelism we need to First
serialize the data move it to another
process or another threat and then
deserialize
again this has very
non-significant uh costs to to be able
to do this in poers we just SharePoint
this and maybe we lock some lock in
mutex some somewhere but um we are very
much designed for Effective parallelism
and our algorithms are designed to be
Lock Free most of the time um it's
designed for outof core processing um
we're getting more and more support for
this that means that we can spill to
disk or we can process data that doesn't
fit into memory by um by by uh working
in batches for instance and and just uh
ensuring that the results get smaller um
and we have tight integration with IO so
this is currently only for local files
we have very tight integration with IO
meaning we directly read into the memory
we need and we don't have any double
copies um for clouds support Cloud
support is getting better in polar but
we still have uh a lot to do we're
relatively naive there yet but we're
getting better the most important thing
in polars is um the API and the
Expressions um and I'm
not this is
um I I cannot sell them completely in
this talk I think um but what we what we
often hear is that people come for
polers for the speed and they stay
because of the composability of our API
if you learn polus Expressions you learn
a new domain specific language and you
can reason about this language and then
you can use this everywhere uh polers
accepts Expressions um in in almost all
these operations and expressions are
building blocks of functions functional
constructs which are pure um they take
in some state of a data frame or series
or a group and it produces an output
series um and what this series can
represent depends on the context it can
represent a column or a group or a list
element or a single value or literal um
but it's very much like a programming
language if you for instance take the
python vocabulary it's it's pretty small
it it fits on a on on a piece of paper I
think but although keywords can be
constructed and composed to be turn and
complete you can do anything with it um
and the expressions
are they're not they're not as rich as
as python of course but they are uh very
powerful and you can combine them
indefinitely you can combine Expressions
um the way you want you can do if else
constructs
um um and you can they are accepted
everywhere so if you're able to do an
expression um we guarantee that it's
runs in parallel we guarantee that it
runs fast um and that we can optimize it
so here is an example of a pivot an
example of a rather complicated
expression which you can do in a pivot
agregation this is just a a trivial
example where expressions are um first
class citizens and are AC are accepted
in almost anywhere in our API um so
they're accepted in select or with
columns in rby in aggregations in pivots
in join Keys um in the future we're also
going to add non joins so you can say
Okay I want to join where
this condition is true and then you can
Define your own own
condition
um and we are so we are so serious about
using Expressions that we even the worst
thing you can do is using a custom
function and apply a Lambda where we had
an expression for this on on the table
so if you use your own custom functions
for instance here you use json. loads
which would require us to materialize
this string to python first do a heap
allocation do the Json loads get a
python string back and uh read that and
push that back into our own memory
format which this would be really
slow uh for one the Heap allocation to
python three because we need to lock the
gild so it's also blocks all parallelism
we can do
so what we do we actually
read uh the bite code of your your past
function and if we can see that we could
replace this with an expression we give
you a warning where we give you um an
example of how you can replace this
expression and we can do pretty cool
stuff like arithmetic um nonp functions
so um yeah uh I'm pretty fond of this I
just think it's cool um
so there's a promise we make with our
API and that is if you use our API
automatically you will get C- speed
that's uh what you get because it's
compiled and rust
factorization um but you get more than
this than when you use numai when you
use numai you only get CS speed when you
use polar you also get optimizations
because polar is lazy and we are able to
uh to prove that we can uh remove some
operations that are necessary
unnecessary or can be done otherwise
second thing you get is parallelism
which you also don't get in numai numai
is eager needs to execute it immediately
and probably might need the previous
result it cannot know how to paralyze it
because it's not lazy so in poish you
get parallelism and effective
parallelism and thirdly you get out of
core processing um which is um yeah this
depends on the operation not all
operations are out of supported out of
core yet but we're getting more and more
operations in out of core so the first
thing as I said is
optimization and different from numai
you only you not only get C performance
but you also get get
optimizations um this here's an example
of a query where we scan a AET file a
scan in polers means we read the file
but we we build a graph a dag of
operations we're going to do so if you
read then it's eager we will read
immediately if you scan we will build
the note of the deck with a promise
we're going to execute this when you're
ready building your deck so that's what
the scan does then we apply a filter we
do a group by and then we do a mean and
a sum aggregation of some multiplication
of two columns and as you can see this
multiplication is done twice right um so
what
polar um I'm I'm going to show this
later but what polus already recognizes
is that this multiplication is done
twice and we only need it once so we can
cach it temporarily um but if you run
this query without optimization it runs
in
1.07 seconds um and if you run this with
CV optimization you get uh a 4.5 times
speed up for free doing nothing uh you
can just write your query semantically
um as it's um as it should be read so
what we what the goal of polar is is
that you can focus on your business
logic and you can write your queries in
a readable fashion and we don't want to
be we don't want to get unreadable
queries because this should be faster
because we should be able to do these
oper these optimizations for
you um so here's one optimization as I
already set this multiplication is
double um so what we do this is called
um common sub expression ex elimination
when we see common sub Expressions we
will cach them temporarily so it will
only be executed once
um and as you build more complicated
Expressions it gets more and more common
to get common sub expressions or if you
have an if else Branch um and you want
to get the result of the predicate also
somewhere in the in the else Branch you
probably also often have uh common
Expressions um here is a a non complete
list of the optimizations we do one
thing we do is checking the schema
polers is strict we need to know the
schema of the data types up front and I
think this is super important you don't
want to be in a query 20 minutes in and
get an error oh expected floats cannot
use this in a in a
hashmap this should be known up front
and in polar the data type is always
depends on the operations and never on
the data the data should not change a
column into a float or a an integer
missing data and none should not change
this um so that's the first thing we do
another thing we do is the the trivial
stuff projection push down predicate
push down which means we look at which
columns you need and only loow the
columns you use uh and the same for
predicates predicates is a fancy name
for filter
we apply them as early as possible um
during the reading pet files have
statistics and sometimes we can even
prove that we don't even need to load
this pet file or this part of a pet file
based on those statistics or even better
sometimes we can prove that we don't
even need to download this part of a
file based on the statistics we do some
joint Branch reordering not super fancy
yet we're going to improve this later we
don't do
join join orders but we swap swap the
branches um if we can prove that one
branch would be faster than the other we
do scan sharing meaning that if a part
of a query or part of a scan is used
multiple times we cach it in between so
you don't load the same file twice uh
common Sub sub plan elimination and
common sub expression elimination we saw
the one uh just yet and type
coercion
um the second thing you get if you use
polers automatically is parall ISM and
we use a technique for that called work
stealing um and work stealing
is super effective I'm going to explain
it a little bit it works with one it's
very cheap um we don't have any
serializations we don't have any tread
or startup cost because we start our
threads uh up front when you start
polars we we allocate a thread pool and
these threads will be used for to
compute heavy stuff uh by default it's
equal to the number of cores on your
machine so for my machine we'll start
with 16 16 threats um and those threads
will be reuse and starting a thread can
cost 100 milliseconds or so so it's it's
non-trivial startup cost um we can every
thread has a cure has a queue dedicated
to the to the to that thread and we can
publish work on this tasks on these cues
and then this this uh um threadpool
thread will just keep finishing its task
right but when a when a thread is
finished um and it's it there's nothing
to do anymore it will steal some work
from a queue from another thread so here
we see this thread is finished it it has
taken half of the work of the other uh
of the other other thread and poers uses
this throughout the library throughout
the framework and um we are actually
very able to get to keep all your course
saturated with useful work it's
important for us that we create tasks
that are somewhat equal as you can
imagine if you have one task that takes
half an hour and the other that's
extreme time but one task that takes
super long and the other the other tasks
already finished you cannot share it so
the task should be um evenly size but
this is something polers tries to do for
you you don't have to think about this
um and because we
allocate um less or equal to the number
of cores on your machine Theos doesn't
need to swap between threads and
swapping between threads is very
expensive if you have thousand threads
and you only have eight cores and you
give all those threads useful work you
will have a lot of overhead of swapping
threads clearing the the state of of
that thread um will be a lot of system
calls um here's an example of how we
deal with the parallelism um where polos
has different strategies depending on
the group on the context you run um so
here we create a data frame with
um I don't I think 10 million rows and 1
million groups and first we count the
number of unique elements and we
multiply it times 10 in a select context
and what we do then is for the N nunique
we create um different task we paraliz
this over all the cues but for the
multiply times two we don't because a
multiply is often very cheap um the the
the threading overhead wouldn't be um
worth it especially if you're talk about
simd acceleration in in in arithmetic so
so the nunique we determined to
parallelize and the times two we don't
in a group by we
create um groups right the group by um
and in this case we have one million
groups um what we do is then we only
parallelize over the groups and we don't
add extra parallelism between the
nunique call because it's not needed to
to also split the nunique again
otherwise you would have a parallel task
with the group and then and unique would
also chart out in more tasks here we
don't do that and again the times two we
ignore the groups because it's cheaper
to um just do it this is an example of
how polar chooses to split up its tasks
it's none we may change this there's no
guarantees here we try to do this in a
smart way under the
hood
um
and yeah as I said we have a threadpool
and this thread pool is concurrence
concurrency aware where so you can it's
not bound to one one CR you can actually
put polers behind the work schedule like
airflow or or web server and push work
on pols and you will not get saturation
of your threads because it would the the
jobs the task will just be added to the
queue and it will it will continue its
work but you will not
um yeah you will not get any any
saturation or any
um um it would not
limit um yeah the the third thing you
get I think it's a bit more obvious is
that you get performance with the
Expressions right if you don't go into
lambas into custom python code um you
get C seight performance because it's
written in Rost um it's and we control
every performance critical code Branch
so we gone through a lot of effort to
use very very false algorithms which are
cash efficient use MD um vector ization
we try very hard to reuse memory buffers
because Heap allocations are very
expensive and we parallelize
effectively um but because of the
Expressions the expressions are superc
composable um it's actually um the
amount of lambas you need the amount of
custom functions udfs you need are way
less than in a tool like bondas for
instance
um and as a result we are very fast
on um local data um we're one of the
fastest uh in memory query engines if if
the data fits in memory um these are the
results of the tpch Benchmark I heard
from Matt that dok will Pro will perform
better with the new version uh so there
will be a new update on this tomorrow
there's a talk on on tpch benchmarks
which scales to uh terabytes um in the
cloud that's something polar
isn't really polers is mostly for local
data if you have local low low latency
data polers will so compute bound data
always is a very good choice um and as
you can see it it's yeah it's uh super
fast so the fourth thing I want to
show um I've been talking a bit about
expressions and if you use the
Expressions you get a lot of benefits
right uh um
but we cannot solve every problem for
you every expression you can think off
and we also don't want it because then
our library would would have a feature
explosion and uh you would need to
download 200 megabytes or 400 megabytes
to to get polers installed so there
needs to be a way for you as a user to
to benefit from this to get expressions
with your business logic um that can
hook in into our engine and that's what
pus plugins is so you are able to
compile your own Ros expressions and
they can link into the default Polar
Engine so you pip install polers you
compile your own Expressions you can
also publish them on pipie you install
this and then we symbolically link your
custom Expressions into our engine you
can register them and you can run them
and you will get all the stuff from
above you will get the parallelism we
don't have to go through python so there
will be no Gill
interference um you get optimizations we
can use some of the characteristics of
the functions so as CSE the common sub
expression elimination we can use that
um the first Clause citizens so
everywhere where we where we accept an
expression we also accept your
expression um yeah
so and as an example I want to make a
piglin converter is anybody familiar
with piglin it's a silly langu language
where you take the first letter put it
at the end and then you add I sort
of pirate so Pig Len would become P Eden
Le Li I don't know how you pronounce Le
um so and we're going to do this in
in okay now let's do it on a few
different ways let's do it first um
naively with with
um with a python Lambda right that would
be
worst um and let's see what's to win
there so here we have a data frame with
5 million elements and 16 columns which
would be 80 million uh
strings strings are expensive data types
um so the naiv way would be a python
function pck glad in
fi I think it's correct correct me if
it's not and then in polers we
can so the commons have are called Comm
Commons zero Commons one we can select
all columns with a uh Rex so this is
very so this expression expands to
multiple expressions and then we apply
this this spig five
function and let's take a look
at oh this doesn't work well let's run
this thing
and the parallelism is super bad as you
can see on top right so this comes due
to Gil locking and he
alocation um the memory is also very bad
I looked at what happens and it seems
the pon
just freeze everything when we give back
the control
um so the memory is not really good but
the parallelism is terrible um and now
it's finished and it's should have taken
approximately 23 seconds um which is
terrible uh a better idea is to use a
polus expression right Pol expressions
are composable we can just make an
expression we take the commons we slice
from the first point and then we take
the first character and add I
right and this should be
faster
so yeah that's already
done
so and as you can see it was completely
parallel right um also way better on
memory but we want to have the fastest
big leadin converter in the world of
course and we want to be this thing to
be super parallel so we're going to
build our
own our own um Pig letin converter and
we can do that who knows a bit of
rust a little bit okay I'm going to not
talk you to it
um rust is Rusty um we can we have a
polar is a data frame Library written in
Ross and you can actually import this
data frame library and compile it we
actually have a front end in R we have a
SQL front end we have a CLI we have a
ruby front end we have a node.js front
end you can take our crate compile it
put your
own your own um language bindings on top
of it you have a data frame library or
query engine so we you can take the
polar crate you can take the P3 polers
that's the crate that helps us derive
our own expression and Surly does some
serialization and deserialization that's
some utility grate we
need and this is a memory allocator you
don't need it it's boiler plate you can
use it it makes stuff faster um and the
first thing we have is a quars keyword
arguments and the arguments if you want
to accept arguments in an expression you
can create your own struct and add
derived the serialize on it and then you
can add anything you want a Boolean an
integer a list and this will work
automatically we will ensure this will
get serialized here we have the function
that computes the that does the
conversion and then we register the
expression itself and the expression
itself is a function that takes us
inputs a r series and the keyword
arguments and then we add a
derive uh boilerplate thing where we say
okay this is a PO expression this is the
output function the output type can be
fixed you can also provide a function
that determines the output type
depending on the input type um and then
we apply
this um yeah this
conversion and that's it then we can
compile this and on the python side we
create a we we create a package with the
name of our uh package and we add an in
it and there's a little bit of
boilerplate we need the lip is get
shared location you can create a
language or any class utility class and
then you can add your own functions and
you see the register name expression the
there you define under which Nam space
this expression will be available so
here we going to use the pig namespace
and then we register the uh um the
plugin and that's it so now we can
compile this
thing voila normally it takes a bit
longer compiling polar isn't it takes
five minutes or so take a cup of coffee
I pre-compile this one um and then what
we can do is just import pig leadin
that's
all and now it's registered and now we
can use the pig pig leify
expression
um and now we have the
fastest well not the f I don't know we
have a very fast parallel big lad Andi
converter also as you can see runs in
parallel we cannot even get up to speed
because it's it's uh
yeah it's done so quickly so this took
368 it's 2.5 something compared to
normal polish expressions and and
compared to the naive solution yeah it's
not really fair right there was 25
seconds 23 um so yeah that's the the
plugins um I want you to
to to take home that the Pol Expressions
allow you to do a lot of stuff and we'll
be super factorized we'll be super
parallel and are super composable and if
you still need to do your own stuff you
can do this with the poish plugins and
you will have the best of both
worlds and as last thing I want to show
is um a bit of how polars is sort of
hybridly out of core so we can process
data sets that don't fit into memory and
if if it if we cannot we don't support
all our whole API in streaming but we
support parts of it and we can do this
hybridly so if the first part of your
query fits in streaming
um then after that we switch to the
default engine and you can continue and
this allows you to process data sets
that don't fited to memory because um
there are a lot of stuff that that uh
reduce data um for instance a group by
reduces the data to the cardinality
right to the cardinality of the groups
um um limits predicates um all this
stuff reduces data this query actually
runs completely memory um but here we
scan a uh pet file I'm going to collect
it to show you the size of this file
it's quite big it
takes
um half of my Ram I
think um
so
let's do something let's start this
again and now we're going to
con uh build a query and we're going to
concatenate this large table four times
so it definitely doesn't fit into RAM
and then we're going to do this this
query the first query of
tpch um and we're going to run it in
streaming mode which means okay try to
use a streaming engine if you can
um
and I just want to show that we are able
to do things super parallel and we can
really work without uh a lot of memory
pressure that's the takeaway I want to
give here and now we're done um
so
the yeah just want to show if you write
your queries aromatically we we should
be able to do things smartly and you
should not be worried with batching and
and uh that kind of
stuff
and that were the takeaways I want to
share um this is my final slide we are
super active on one on gith up um and
two on Discord there there's a lot of
people helping out so if you got
questions go to Discord say hi um yeah
uh say hi and thank
[Applause]
you yes what was the difference between
the the the plugin what happened that
you TR to speed up by making our
own versus the Expressions Expressions
right
well um let me go to and expressions
are where is the
expression here's the
expression Expressions run vectorized so
what will have um in the plugin I
created the function and pass it to llm
or lvm which is a highper performance
Optimizer which will do all kinds of
stuff to to optimize this function to
work effectively right and it doesn't
have to do in Heap allocation because we
also know how to write it to a buffer in
this case polus is pre-compiled and the
expressions are generic and they work
factorized and we can run stuffff uh you
you give us but we have to run them
vectorized so here we run first the slid
we will create uh the First Slice which
um will do a heap allocation of of the
and then we do another slice and then we
add add this so you do three operations
vectorized but this operations the
compiler so the polar has a op Optimizer
which can Shuffle operations can change
operations but we don't have a big
linier in our uh in our engine so it
will have to do do this in a vectorized
way which cannot be as optimized as
writing this function in Rust and doing
things smartly right so it can even be
that that there is some simd
optimization in the
function uh that the lvm optimizer found
but yeah the
yeah I really like to uh import um Pig
Latin part the fact that it ties into
python can you talk about the magic for
like how you get the compiled rust to be
like importable
um the magic are we get so so on the
rust side or on the python side uh how
did so we compile that pig LA exension
and then you were able to import it you
know as if it was like a package yeah so
there was some boiler plates in
the here is a boilet plate get shared Li
location and the compiled the compiled
function gets stored in the in the you
can see it here it gets stored in the in
the package also if you build a wheel
package it gets the compiled code is
next to the package so it's on the same
location so we ask you to get the shared
Library location and then you need to
register it here and then uh at run time
we will link so the polarus engine will
take this information it will link the
them and and then it will call the
function when it's needed um but on the
moment we call this function we don't
need any python right we know this is
the binary this is the location in the
binary file you just you only pay for
virtual function call which in the in
the sense of python is is very cheap
um yeah other
question um so my team uses number plus
num yeah to kind accomplish the same
thing with plugin is accomplishing um we
are considering switching to polers but
I don't think I could convince any of my
colleagues to start writing rust plugins
right um is there any chance that this
could be lifted into like a python uh
ecosystem like this this plugin featur
you just write in pure Python and
somehow it calls lbm just like does wow
that's a whole lot of project for
me um no I don't have any I mean you're
asking for a rust or what we need would
be a uh like a siphon for rust yeah yeah
you need new
coworkers yeah but the thing is what I
want to so I
hope rust isn't it's got a steep
learning curve true but if you write
easy rust with cloning you're already
way faster than doing this UDF stuff and
if you look
at if you do arithmetic or but call a
distance function
um that part of Ross isn't that hard I
think the lifetimes is hard the trades
but I think the kind of stuff you want
to write as a as a plug-in the basic
stuff the initial stuff we already have
a a business day plugin which gets in an
integer which represents some Epoch time
uh the Unix Epoch and they do some
arithmetic to with the Chrono library
and I you can hack that ARR I I'm I
trust you you can
uh um so I hope I understand what you
say but I don't think it's the the bar
is super high you can already get a lot
of added value by doing it in the naive
way yeah so regarding the scan part do
you use like P internally or use no we
have our own parquet reader we uh build
first initially on Arrow two now we
forked ar2 and polers uh we I
implemented the CSV parser we use simd
for Json but everything is in poers so
we have a rust grade and everything must
be compiled with us because we want we
don't want to be dependent on python
because we also have an r package we
have a SQL CLI we we want to be we want
to be actually we want be sort of a
bootstrapper of of query answer data
frames if you start a new language and
need a data frame please come to us we
solved a lot of problems already uh and
you can you don't have to adhere to our
API you can build your own API on top
that's actually what happens in Elixir
Elixir has got a data frame Library
called Explorer which has built upon
polar and um actually just uses polar
every so every month when we make a new
release they update
their um yeah their po engine but you
mention in your group by example that
that group bu parallel applies determine
the groups before do that cashing the
group or depends on the engine we have
two engines the streaming engine and the
uh default engine the default engine
computes the groups before does this
lock free with Radix
partitioning
um and well actually we have yet another
if we we sample first the cardinality in
the default engine and if the
cardinality is low we go to another
engine as well
um group Buys have very different
results depending on cardinalities and
you need not just one algorithm because
then you will be slow on um on the
streaming engine
we uh the group by is streaming we we
compute the groups as they come and we
keep a Hot Table of hot groups in memory
and gr if the table grows and we get
have a high cardinality we start to
spill out to partitionings and if these
partitions tend to go out of memory then
we spill those partitions to dis and we
um so we do this partially hot tables in
memory and and then we have less hot or
cool tables for the the the call the
groups um but there the groups are
determined while we get the data yeah
yeah does that answer the question Yeah
Yeah question out memory are you using
basically like thish yeah yeah we so the
worst thing you can do is let the as
swap yeah that's and it happens
sometimes if you have polar's default
engine we can swap and sometimes people
say hey this is slow but yeah okay at
this point you're not benchmarking
anything because uh swapping is the the
worst thing that can happen so but we
have a lot of information we know what's
happening we know which data we need
which we know which data we don't need
so um what we spill to partitions
depending on the algorithm these
partitions mean something uh sometimes
we just we don't need petitions we can
just spill to dis it depends on the
operation um how we
spill
yeah y you're crazy man
congratulations thank
you oh cool yeah thanks oh um I hope you
get happy uses we move really fast uh if
you have an issue open issue and
probably is solved within a week and
released as well um we really like this
false space because we get a lot of
information out a lot of feedback and um
this way you can also steer where we're
going um
yeah cool thank
[Applause]
you